and also echoes not an outbreak he's my
boy maybe is you okay drone you know
zombies are already these what's
it's is Michael living in the office
here not secured even I told them that
just no talk - hey Michael is everything
okay what are you doing
so yeah I'm just playing for tonight
you just like 45 million 50 million
people playing that now yeah the game is
popping right now a lot of people are
jumping on also because it's free to
play but I think 45 million was last
number that we got in terms of how many
people are playing this game people do
like free right yeah that's interesting
save the world was really well liked I
liked it I know you didn't like it so
much I had a great time with the
building battle system I know you guys
all heard a star Hawk back in the day
what's up game spotters this is Aaron
Sampson with the star Hawk starter guide
star Hawk is a third-person shooter with
RTS mechanics that requires you to have
the brain of an engineer and the twitch
shooting skills of well you know a gamer
is like the first building battle game
at pads in Starhawk and Billy Fortresses
is super creative but yeah like you said
that's not what's bringing people back
to this game it's people who are
thinking about pub G and saw free
version yeah they thirsty for battle
royale style but of course you know pub
she wasn't on consoles initially now
it's on Xbox one but it's also late
thirty bucks but I think that you know
this is a free to play alternative the
thing about this though it's not like a
tactical shooter like pub G is I did
that pub G fortnight comparison and I
would say that pub she plays a lot like
Rainbow six whereas fortnight plays a
lot more like an arena shooter so in
that way I think it's more accessible
but then also the building mechanics you
know I'm really getting the hang of the
building mechanics in fortnight and I
think that's what makes this game very
special it's weird how well the building
fits into the battle rail formula in the
original game like we kind of differ I
was saying for tonight
vanilla whatever you want to call it
however many different price options
there are the building obviously like
the game is structured around the
progression whereas in this one it's fun
to see how people use the building when
they're within a circle if you'd built a
tower to have a better vantage point but
then they could shoot you out from
underneath
there's a video a highlight reel the
other day where someone just was like
throwing up walls as the minigun was
just shredding them and they finally got
up next to the person the minigun and
smoke them it's crazy how you can
actually like use the same mechanics
from the vanilla game in this like you
know emerging genre sub-genre whatever
you want yeah especially especially in
the late game when you get to like that
final zone you see these like five six
storey buildings already like thrown up
you were playing that one time when you
were spectating after you died and then
they know to get up to that six storey
building someone just built a huge
staircase in a matter of seconds
basically like this giant brick tidal
wave this they were they're actually
losing and they baited the other team
with some walls because they knew they
would shoot the walls sniped him out of
the corner of the screen and then
overcame them with a giant brick tidal
wave that level creativity's is really
what distinguishes this game now I think
when everybody started playing this game
off of pub G they were playing it like
pub G and that's why everybody thought
it was the same game but yet now now
that we're deep into this thing it's way
less about hiding in a field at the end
and and more about dominating the spaces
that are left over with your tower and
destroying other people's towers
I think it's been sort of the year
Battle Royale and it'd be really
interesting to see other games chase
that I know a lot of people wanted out
of Ghost Recon wildlands battlefield but
to four nights credit to epics credit
they were able to adapt really quickly
and make a battle royale and I think a
lot of games backends are not designed
for that the crew knows if if wild ends
can even do it if they wanted to say
whatever you want about like fortnight
the base game the original game what was
intended to release but that had a sound
foundation like you know there wasn't
that many glitches it ran well on PC it
was able to run well on consoles so
expanding that like taking like this
thing to Battle Royale like you kind of
overcome the problems of pub G that has
like optimization issues and stuff like
that you know you already had a big good
foundation right there to convert the
game to battle royale and while
retaining the crafting mechanics this
makes it stand out because it's not just
a clone anymore it's you know it's a
crafting game it's you know gathering
resources which you don't really really
have to do in pub G they're also really
smell with their timed events like
they're doing snipers and pistols only
and a couple other things it's there's a
lot of other titles that aren't doing
that right now like they're really
getting the overwatch thing like limited
time skins limited time modes and those
are great because then you can test
things out and if they don't work you're
just like yeah it was a limited time
mode you know they do work they become a
staple in your game
I have friends who to a traditionally
play game especially not pub G but even
they are getting into this and then
you're on like Instagram and some way
team accounts are using for night say
fooled might play around bones
battlegrounds I've seen like frat party
memes where people are playing for a
night it's crazy how much this exploded
he's got what more players in pop G now
right like IO any pub G's at how many
now it's old what I remember they forgot
they crossed the twenty million
threshold
yeah they curse like people were
throwing around 30 million yeah and this
is what at least 45 has of a couple
weeks ago I have to imagine it's only
gotten bigger because those you like
they're slowing down
I will say that one really awesome thing
is to watch all of these games start
small and succeed as opposed to like the
big blockbuster launches right now we've
got a couple games like this in Rainbow
six siege and even pub g4 tonight that
started small and are growing these
massive fan bases like organically and
that's kind of exciting from from our
perspective come on
all right check out my setup right here
you know people thinking I'm living in
here but I'm really not despite what
Mike says let me show you all my setup I
got a wireless mouse 50 hundred colors
RGB keyboard right here I got my game of
fuel my Joey knows without me a coke
zero zero calories stay slim yo I got
like five headset so I only got like two
years through iPhone noobs and for
tonight alright y'all got to leave so
thanks for rolling through peace out
y'all
[Music]